[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ensemble nous
ferons la tour de l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
le sommaire de ce vendredi 18 octobre le
4 juillet dernier la station d'épuration
à achères été victime d'un incendie
une semaine après des centaines de
poissons ont été retrouvés morts dans la
seine depuis la préfecture fait des
points réguliers de la situation jeudi
17 octobre avait lieu la 4ème réunion
d'information comme tous les ans les 259
mairie blinois se sont donné rendez vous
aux universités les mairies cette année
ils ont également invité leurs collègues
des hauts de seine
nous reviendrons pour cet événement avec
notre invité le président de
l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines une crèche à la gare de
villiers n'opte pour chartrand le tour
de france 2020 qui passera par notre la
jolie et l'open de golf qui a débuté ce
jeudi au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines vous feront le tour sur
l'actualité qui a marqué le département
cette semaine
[Musique]
un peu plus de trois mois après l
incendie survenu à la station
d'épuration d'achères une quatrième
réunion d'information s'est déroulée
jeudi 17 octobre à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
le point avec ohrid rose et gris lorik
cana des représentants de l'état du
siaap élus et associations ils se sont
une nouvelle fois réunis pour faire le
point sur les conséquences de l'incendié
survenu le 3 juillet dernier à la
station d'épuration d'achères
souvenez-vous plusieurs tonnes de
poissons morts avaient été repêchés dans
la seine
si la cause de l'incendié n'est pas
encore trouvé à ce jour l'activité de
traitement des eaux usées fonctionne à
plus de 90% et d'amélioration
substantielle va avoir lieu à partir du
14 novembre puis des travaux
complémentaires vont être engagés
notamment pour la détection incendie et
ces travaux seront terminés au 28
février prochain et puis nous aurons un
retour progressif à la pleine capacité
mais en effet ça prend du temps environ
quatre années encore le préfet des
yvelines a par ailleurs prescrits et
plusieurs audits concernant notamment la
sécurité
de son côté le siaap le syndicat
interdépartemental pour l'assainissement
de l'agglomération parisienne se veut
rassurant ce qui s'est passé lors de
l'incident
c'est qu'on n'a pas pu accepter les eaux
d'égout pas arriver avec
les pollutions humaines et qui a
consommé l'oxygène dans la seine
dégradants et s'élève manque d'oxygène
dans la seine qui a fait que les
poissons sont morts par asphyxie mais
n'y a pas eu de produits chimiques dans
la scène donc on voit bien que ces
équipements soient absolument nécessaire
avec l'audit doit travailler aussi à
faire avancer sur comment avoir une
redondance ou du moins schéma de secours
en cas de nouveau problème
en plus de ces audits un plan
particulier d'intervention sera mise en
place
sa consultation est possible jusqu'au 5
novembre sur le site de la préfecture
des yvelines ainsi que dans les communes
concernées
une cinquième réunion est également
prévue à la mi-décembre en
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
[Musique]
dans son discours prononcé au congrès
national de l'association des maires
ruraux de france le 20 septembre dernier
le premier ministre edouard philippe
alerter sur les préjugés de la ruralité
je cite entre le bonheur est dans le pré
est la terre de zola il ya de la place
pour une infinie variété de situations
avec des territoires ruraux qui vont
très bien d'autres qui sont dans une
grande difficulté
et puis on l'oubli mais l'exode rural
est derrière nous aujourd'hui la
population des campagnes augmentent plus
vite que celle des villes clés de
gestion vous êtes avec nous ou bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de
l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines également maire de mirecourt
une commune d'un peu plus de 430
habitants les communes rurales des
yvelines elles sont à l'image de ce qu'a
dit edouard philippe
oui oui oui nos communes regagnant
population c'est d'ailleurs assez
paradoxal c'est au moment où on a eu un
mouvement de l'état qui tentait faire
disparaître un peu les communes celle là
elle est en train de reprendre tout leur
rôle et une regagnant population aussi
en développement économique commune qui
vont bien d'autres moments dans les
événements représentative de sa oui oui
c'est vrai on a on a malgré tout des
communes qui sont assez des zones assez
reculée il ya encore des zones blanches
des eaux n'y a pas de transports
collectifs
voilà donc sipa transports collectifs ça
veut dire pas d'accès à la culture aux
grands équipements voilà c'est tout et
des problématiques que nous devons
régler aussi dans les yvelines mérité à
l'honneur cette semaine les plus
précisément mercredi se sont déroulées
les universités des mairies à port marly
c'est le rendez vous des maires des
yvelines pour cette édition 2010 9
l'événement était organisé avec
l'association des maires du haut de
seine toute la journée les élus
municipaux ont pu rencontrer des
partenaires et échanger sur leurs
conditions d'exercice
reportage de nicolas landry et grégory
canale
ils sont 2 159 dans les yvelines 36 dans
les hauts-de-seine les maires des deux
départements avaient rendez vous pour la
première fois ensemble aux universités
des mairies des ateliers des tables
rondes organisées pour les élus
municipaux avec notamment des
partenaires d'autres collectivités
lamentable le département est tout à
fait la nécessaire pour que nous les
maires puissent travailler
bonne intelligence et avec cette
reconnaissance de la tan
si le contexte est difficile les
communes peuvent bénéficier des devenant
des intercommunalités des départements
des régions et de l'état à travers les
services déconcentrés des aides sur le
vélo des aides sur les transports
propres des aides sur le verdissement de
la ville des aides sur le patrimoine
avec un bonus de 200 mille euros pour
tous les villages qui ont des besoins de
rénovation de patrimoine je n'oppose pas
la nécessaire décentralisation et son
approfondissement à un état qui soit
renforcée sur le territoire antagonisent
et les uns les autres n'a pas de sens
nous avons besoin les uns des autres des
partenaires privés présente du secteur
de l'immobilier des travaux publics ou
du transport avec de curieuses
découvertes comme le gouvernail un
mélange entre la boussole et la carte un
moyen d'information pour se déplacer et
valoriser le patrimoine d'une commune
une idée de la start-up bug lancé il ya
moins d'un an
je veux par exemple aller sur le stand
de la sncf je sais pas où est ce qu'on
le sent la sncm où j'ai juste à chercher
à la lettre s sncf qui sont en secteur 3
je prends gouvernail je tourne avec lui
positionne du secteur 3 devant moi et
voilà je vois immédiatement sncf
je me suis mis physiquement et
mentalement face à ma destination
cette solution pourrait apparaître
prochainement dans les rues yvelinoise
et plusieurs émissions ont été
enregistrées durant seize universel
universités des mairies par notre chaîne
tv façon 18 pour les retrouver au
courant de la semaine prochaine sur
notre site internet et les objections
vous y étiez à ces universités des
mérites pourquoi est ce intéressant d'y
aller c'est l'événement de l'année pour
tous les élus yves desdoit c'est
l'occasion de se rencontrer dans un
cadre convivial c'est bon on l'a vu dans
le reportage c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer le président du département
l'imposante de la région le président du
sénat l'autre préfet qui était présent
et qui ont participé voilà c'est
l'occasion de pouvoir échanger avec eux
dans un cadre plutôt sympathique
rencontrer aussi les partenaires et
voilà et nous aussi autres élus puisque
ça change un peu des instances dans
lesquelles on a l'habitude de se
rencontrer et voilà c'est un événement
que je trouve incontournable pour tous
les élus dans le reportage on l'a vu la
mère de plaisir parle de l'importance de
la proximité du lien c'est ce que vous
recherchez quand vous allez à ce genre
d'événement bien sûr absolument relever
on a besoin on l'a vu avec la présidente
de la région
cd franchement valérie pécresse depuis
qu'elle est arrivée à la région c'est
devenu un vrai partenaire pour nous et
mais on a aussi besoin du département
parce que le département est le
principal financeur aussi de nos
communes voilà et c'est l'occasion dû te
ment de mettre tous ces gens en relation
et de parler de nos projets et de les
faire mûrir ensemble des tables rondes
ou alors pour le coup j'ai pas
participer à l'atelier ce que j'avais un
rendez vous avec le président larcher
pendant les ateliers du matin pour
parler justement de la ruralité et puis
des réformes territoriales et leurs
conséquences sur notre territoire mais
je sais que voilà john billard le vice
président de la lrf était venu pour
parler
la première cabine de télémédecine qui
l'a mis en place sur sa commune et
parler du numérique également mais voilà
il y avait toujours des
des ateliers et des tables rondes qui
sont de très haute qualité dans la tête
dans l'actualité ces derniers mois on a
vu plusieurs maires jeter l éponge
démissionner renoncé à se présenter aux
futures élections municipales qu'est ce
qui a conduit à ce climat là les
réformes qu'on appelle les lois notre et
emma pts amant vraiment abîmé la commune
est abîmé le mandat de maire on a un
mandat qui est très très compliqué tout
simplement ce qu'on a on à marier de
force des communes qui n'en avaient pas
l envie ni le besoin
ça a créé ça a créé un climat qui n'est
pas très sain pour le fonctionnement de
nos institutions
l'opération oui c'est très compliqué les
élus ont perdu on a perdu des
compétences on a perdu en proximité avec
nos habitants on est souvent éloignée
notre territoire sous des réunions sont
à l'extérieur des communes
voilà tout un tas de facteurs qui fait
que
beaucoup d'élus se sont sentis un peu
dépassé par les événements on est
submergé submergé de réunion et surtout
de l'information papier et d'information
par mail moi je reçois à peu près 150 m
par jour donc il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
n'ont pas de secrétariat
le x objet de traiter va des petits élus
qui sont obligés de traiter ses
informations seules et au bout d'un
moment ils décrochent
comment faire pour remédier à cela et
bien il faut il faut il faut remettre le
maire au centre au centre des décisions
lui redonner lui redonner la place qui
était la sienne
par exemple sur des grandes
intercommunalités comme comme l'a gps
aux communautés urbaines grand paris
seine et oise
je pense qu'il faut revoir
l'organisation de ce cette grosse
cette grosse machine est peut-être la
réorganiser autour de pôles et de
manière à ce que les élus du mantois
puisse travailler sur des problématiques
du mantois et ceux de conflans ou
d'archet rompois ci puissent travailler
chez eux sur leurs problématiques
propres et puis de temps en temps bien
sûr autour des instances comme la
conférence des maires se retrouver pour
parler des grands sujets à l'occasion de
ces universités des mairies justement
représentants de l'état élus locaux et
monde agricole se sont réunis pour
signer un document la charte de bon
voisinage
elle a pour but de mettre fin à ce qu'on
appelle communément la grille bashing
c'est à dire le dénigrement des
agriculteurs signature dans un contexte
particulier dans les yvelines
trois communes ont pris des arrêtés anti
pesticides la charte engage les
agriculteurs vis-à-vis des habitants sur
un certain nombre de points
on écoute le président de la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france au micro
de grégory canale et nicolas d'andré
qu'on s'engage à utiliser notamment tota
technique qui permet la limite de
dérives de nos produits phytosanitaires
par l'utilisation par exemple de buses
anti dérive par un certain nombre de
facteurs qui sont déjà prévues par la
loi mais par exemple le fait de passer
un permis à traiter la transparence sont
notre façon de travailler
la réduction des doses ne pas traiter à
des ventes plus de 19 km heure enfin
tout un tas de facteurs aujourd'hui qui
sont très engageant pour l'agriculteur
que la population voit sans doute pas
mais qui vise à limiter justement cet
impact et le risque qui pourrait y avoir
en fait vis-à-vis des habitants
le lendemain de cette signature la ville
de renvoyer rapporté un incident sur sa
commune les habitants m'ont appelé la
mairie pour signaler un épandage un col
à l'odeur nauséabonde épandage qui a été
contrôlé par la police municipale la
mairie rapporte sur son site internet
que le produit était un adjuvant 100%
végétale et le vieillissement ça arrive
souvent ce genre de situation oui ça
peut arriver mais bon les odeurs c'est
pas souvent ce qui pollue le plus a
évidemment c'est désagréable
c'est désagréable on l'a le cas souvent
avec les épandages mais pour revenir sur
votre reportage
il faudrait pas faire des agriculteurs
des martyrs moi je pense que évidemment
les élus ont tous à coeur d'avoir une
commune dans lequel on peut respirer un
bonnaire et et que nos populations
soient en toute sécurité
mais moi je trouve que le problème des
le problème des épandages de pesticides
et des produits phytosanitaires c'est un
problème qui relève à la faute d'une
femme du scientifique est aussi hors
cadre et par la loi il paraît difficile
pour les élus que nous sommes à moins
d'être un élu qui est connaisseur de
prendre un arrêté qui va à l'encontre de
la loi voilà après il faut moi je pense
qu'il faut travailler avec les
agriculteurs
il faut pas voilà faut leur laisser le
temps de s'adapter ça fait 50 ans qu'on
est dans une agriculture assez intensive
voilà il faut changer de modèle mais il
faut les accompagner notre agriculture
c'est le fleuron de c'est un fleuron
national mais voilà il faut pas va pas
se passer nos agriculteurs comme ça
cette charte bon voisinage ça peut être
une bonne solution pour rétablir un peu
le lien entre les agriculteurs et leurs
voisins
exactement exactement c'est voilà il
faut commencer par ça c'est très bien
vous restez avec nous nous avons parlé
d'une initiative de la région ile de
france et de la sncf
une micro crèche dans une gare c'est ce
doute bénéficie dix enfants de moins de
3 ans dont les parents sont des usagers
des transports depuis septembre à la
gare de villé neauphle pochard train un
espace de 140 m² pour un coût total de
500 mille euros d'ici 2024 20 projets
petite enfance devrait ouvrir sous le
même modèle dans la région deux à quatre
encadrants sont sur place et s'adapte
aux horaires des parents comme explique
estelle chevallier au micro de michael
et demi d'euros on peut imaginer un
train en retard la personne
et plus assurés de pouvoir récupérer ses
enfants de manière voilà comme le train
de choix sont arrivés en retard le
personnel de la crèche peu voilà être
avoir une indulgence qu'on n'a pas
forcément ailleurs dans les autres
crèches une crèche dans une gare rural
ce mot nouvelle très bien oui oui swiss
et il ya une demande et je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir récupéré des mètres
carrés inutilisés maintenant pour en
faire voilà des microcrèches on peut
aussi les transformer pour faire autre
chose comme du coworking du télétravail
a peut-être d'autres services aussi à
mettre dans ses envois mais pour le coup
ça rend d'énormes services à nos
habitants qui vont qui habite à la
campagne mais qui continue à travailler
à la ville justement la petite enfance
est souvent une problématique qui
revient dans les petites communes n'y a
pas forcément de crèches foudroyé
regarde on n'a pas de crèche on n'a pas
beaucoup d'assistantes maternelles
justement charge à nous élus locaux de
de mettre à disposition des lieux où on
pourrait réunir des assistantes
maternelles pour avoir un endroit où les
parents un endroit fin unique où les
parents pourraient justement venir
déposer rechercher leurs petits bambins
avant de avant d'aller au travail ça
permettrait aussi d'avoir des amplitudes
horaires suffisamment importante pour
que les parents puissent prendre le
train le matin de bonne heure autres
lieux qui peuvent manquer dans les
communes rurales
on parlait alors des zones blanches mais
il ya aussi un problème de médecin de
médecins de campagne alors ça ça fait
partie d'une des propositions qu'on a
fait pour la gendarmerie nous ce qu'on
demande c'est que les étudiants du
dernier cycle puisse venir faire un
stage d'au moins six mois dans les
communes rurales sur d'anchois dans les
cabinets soit dans les choix dans les
maisons de santé
ça permettrait de de leur faire
connaître découvrir nos territoires
ruraux
aujourd'hui les jeunes médecins vont se
vont s'implanter plus tôt en ville est
plutôt dans le sud de la france
voilà et pour le coup ça leur
permettrait de découvrir des zones
rurales et la viralité qui est une vie
aussi formidable finition nous arrivons
à la fin de cette rente sentir merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau je le
rappelle vous êtes président de
l'association des maires ruraux de
france et maire de méricourt la saison
estivale s'est terminée le 21 septembre
l'occasion pour le département de
publier son étude sur la fréquentation
touristique 1 et était 1019 considéré
comme un bon cru dans la lignée de 2010
8 18% des sites enregistrent une
fréquentation inhabituelle entre juin et
août
année record pour le musée d'archéologie
nationale de saint germain en laye avec
une progression de 24 % d'entrées
meilleure année depuis 50 ans pour la
direction du château de breteuil à
choisel + 16 % de fréquentation aux au
safari de thoiry stabilité enfin du côté
du château de versailles avec plus de 3
millions de visiteurs enregistrés en
revanche le bilan est plus mitigé du
côté des hôteliers 68% d'entre eux
estiment que la saison était moyennes
voire mauvaises et à vercel justement ou
le potager du roi se retrouve au coeur
d'une polémique
le 4 octobre dernier un article du
figaro titre et la lente agonie du
potager du roi accusé de ne plus
s'occuper des arbres fruitiers mais
aussi de laisser les murs et et d aller
à l'abandon et jardiniers et l'école
nationale supérieure de paysages
prennent la parole pour rétablir la
vérité
reportage de mathilde de 2010 le potager
du roi est au coeur d'une controverse
suite à l'article du figaro du 4 octobre
2019 qui explique photos à l'appui
la dégradation du jardin l'école
nationale supérieure de paysage rappelle
que la construction du potager a
commencé en 1678 et que de nombreuses
restaurations ont été faites
malgré le manque de mécénat
effectivement les les photos montrent
des murs qui sont dans un état
dégradé puisque nous avons fait des
diagnostics assez approfondies et on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a une part
importante des murs 15% des murs qui
nécessite une intervention urgente 30%
qui nécessitent des interventions
rapides mais effectivement nous sommes
en mesure aujourd'hui de déployer un
programme de travaux des parcelles vides
ou abîmées des murs et qui s'effrite des
arbres en mauvais état pour cela 4 5
millions d'euros vont être utilisés pour
des travaux de rénovation
l'objectif du potager et de retirer les
arbres pour reconstruire les murs et du
jardin puis replantés les espèces des
travaux qui commenceront fin 2019 et qui
s'étendront sur 2020
quand on refait un mur ça veut pas dire
que tout d'un coup il ya d un fruitier
dessus il ya du temps un temps de
conservation de préservation nos sols et
à un temps de remise en vie de nos sols
il ya un temps de mise en place sur le
mur le temps que le mur lui même
on va dire arrête de bouger
donc il faut compter entre le moment où
un mur héros fait est que ce mur est
beau d'un point de vue de la production
il faut compter bien 8,9 peut-être même
dix ans des dégradations datant depuis
la fin du 19ème siècle qui s'accumulent
et qui nécessitent aujourd'hui de
nombreuses restaurations les jardiniers
du potager du roi prévoit donc le
renouvellement du patrimoine arboré dans
les années à venir
on l'a appris ce mardi le tour de france
2020 passera par les yvelines après où
en 2018 est embrouillée en 2019
le département va accueillir pour la
troisième année consécutive la grande
boucle cette année c'est la ville de
mantes la jolie qui a été retenue pour
recevoir l'événement le 19 juillet
prochain
la dernière fois que la bulle la ville
l'a vu passer des cyclistes entre
maillot jaune et blanc c'était en 2014
lors de l'étape amiens chartres mais ce
n'est pas vraiment une surprise le
département des yvelines et le groupe
alès aux organisateurs du tour de france
avait signé en mars 2019 une convention
pour accueillir les dernières étapes du
tour de france jusqu'en 2023
on écoute alexandre joly vice-présidente
déléguée aux sports interrogée par
michael et demi d'eau
il faut se souvenir que 2024 sera
l'année des jeux olympiques et que
département accueillera le vélo mais
au-delà de ça le vélo dans les yvelines
c'est un bel os partage sa vélo pour
visiter c'est aussi un vélo santé c'est
un vélo pour tous puisque le département
à 850 km de voies cyclables
nous avons le cyclisme le golfe depuis
jeudi a débuté la 103e édition de l'open
de france au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
trois français participent à la
compétition victor dubuisson alexander
hleb et victor perez après deux jours de
qualification jeudi et vendredi les
derniers tours seront pour ce week end
près de 20000 personnes présentes sur
cette date automnale inhabituelle pour
cet événement programmé généralement
pendant l'été le directeur du golf
national micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude unique l ennemi d'euros c'est
différent parce que on est on est pas du
tout à nos dates depuis 15 ans dans
l'habitude d'avoir le dernier week-end
de juin au premier week-end de juillet
et là on est mi octobre donc ça nous
change au niveau de la physionomie un
peu au niveau des vêtements par exemple
mais mais franchement il ya de quoi
amusé et occuper le public qui vient du
19 au 21 octobre une troupe de 40
artistes se produit à versailles
il s'agit d'un cirque musical qui
racontent sous un chapiteau l'histoire
de phinéas dès lors le créateur de site
du cirque moderne aux états unis ce
projet est né dans les yvelines à
versailles
or ils iront et mathilde et demi on peut
suivre les répétitions ils sont 25 sur
scène à danser chanter et déclamer ses
bénévoles font partie de l'association
le cirque musical
leur projet est réinterprété sous forme
de comédie musicale l'histoire de
phinéas taylor barnum le créateur du
cirque moderne aux états unis c'est en
voyant le film the greatest showman avec
hugh jackman que le président de
l'association versaillaise a décidé de
lancer ce projet certains disent que
c'était un gredin et qu' il s'est servi
de beaucoup de gens d'autres retiendront
plutôt que c'était quelqu'un qui avait
un grand coeur et qui s'est du coup
inspiré de ces personnes là et qui leur
a donné un lieu pour s'exprimer et donc
jeu on a retenu cette histoire vision
d'accueil
cette vision de partage sur une scène
autour d'un show il s'agit de la
première comédie musicale sous chapiteau
avec les personnes en coulisses cette
troupe d'amateurs et de semi
professionnel est composé d'une
quarantaine de bénévoles
au coeur de cette aventure artistique la
sublimation des 10
l'interprète de la chanson this is me
donc une chanson qui valent vraiment de
blessure c'est la voilà quand les ti la
femme à barbe se fait rejeter de la
troupe
et d'ailleurs ça me touche énormément
fait de travailler texte de vraiment de
ça en excellent exercice de théâtre
d'aller rechercher ses propres aux
blessés en fait c'est propre ça
s'apprend que ça et après 2 voilà d'être
un peu écorché vif
en fait certaines 17 dates sont
programmées pour cette tournée d'automne
six représentations auront lieu à
versailles à partir du 19 octobre
[Musique]
à l'occasion du mois d et dans un
appartement témoin présente en seine et
marne de nombreuses adaptations et
matériels pour faciliter la vie des
personnes âgées à domicile
reportage de nos confrères via grand
pagne la salle de bains un piège pour
les personnes âgées
c'est le premier lieu d'accident on peut
pourtant prévenir les chutes
grâce à quelques aménagements très
simple pour les baignoires par exemple
vous pouvez trouver une planche de bain
donc on file sur la baignoire et donc
avec celles ci on va pouvoir s'installer
dessus et éviter les chutes qu'on
pourrait avoir en franchissant la
baignoire
ici on a un réhausseur de wc donc ça ça
va aider les personnes qui en ont besoin
à se lever plus facilement ici on va
avoir quelque chose qui évite de se
baisser pour se laver les pieds là on va
trouver un tabouret qu'on installe dans
la douche
donc comme la douche c'est instable
voilà ça va éviter de glisser vers la
douche bien vivre le plus longtemps
possible c'est rester chez soi de
nombreuses adaptations et matériels sont
proposés pour faciliter la vie des
personnes âgées des solutions qui
existent aussi pour leur permettre
d'adapter leurs loisirs à leur handicap
on va pouvoir par exemple de s'équiper
avec des téléphones à grosses touches on
a les problèmes cognitifs de
l'assomption vers des difficultés pour
pour se repérer également dans l'espace
ou dans le temps ou des systèmes de
téléphone avec rappelle par exemple
monde votre intéressant et puis on va
avoir les problèmes de personnes qui
votent isolées socialement avec la
fracture numérique et là on a
aujourd'hui des outils informatiques qui
peuvent
être facilitant pour des seniors qui
sont en difficultés pour communiquer
avec l'extérieur
la déficience visuelle est un des plus
gros handicap chez les seniors il existe
aujourd'hui tout un tas de techniques
l'aider loupe grossissante des systèmes
de loupe électronique mais aussi des
petits objets usuels du quotidien tels
des cartes qui vont être grossi pour
pouvoir permettre aux personnes a basis
ion de pouvoir jouer avec avec leurs
proches
ces aménagements et ses matériels
peuvent être financés par le département
de seine-et-marne
nous pouvons prendre en charge
financièrement un certain nombre des
deux techniques qu'elles sont présentées
ici des aides réversible pas
d'adaptation de logements proprement
parler mais des aides pratiques pour
manger se déplacer vivre travailler
entre guillemets revoir une activité est
resté donc actif même avec le grand h
cet appartement qui présente des espaces
de vie d'une habitation partir à la
rencontre du grand public dans divers
lieux du territoire gares centres
commerciaux prochain salon des seniors
objectif venir au plus près des milliers
de seine et marnais qui aident un proche
âgé ou handicapé c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi on se
quitte avec des images de la fabrication
d'une robe ou chocolat retour sur
l'actualité dès lundi dans le street
journal bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]